bit of breaking news to bring you now uh  This concerns uh an extradition case  that's been appearing before the  Scottish courts uh the identity of a man  facing extradition who U.S officials  believe is The Wanted rape suspect  Nicholas Rossi has been confirmed today  uh Mr Rossi as a well he claimed to be  called Arthur Knight an orphaned from  Ireland who suddenly found himself in  Scotland he's 35 years old he's wanted  on various charges in the United States  two allegations of rape and one of  sexual assaults have been made against  him and it's been allegedly faked his  own death and fled to Scotland to escape  prosecution where in the last few  moments the Scottish courts have ruled  that this gentleman is indeed Nicholas  Rossi and he will accordingly be  extradited to the United States